well the golden knights hit the ice for
the fourth time this season vegas
is playing the arizona coyotes for the
second game in a row
john treach joins us live here in the
studio and i know that the knights are
trying to stay undefeated in year four
right
yeah that's right it's only been three
games but it's felt like an odyssey
through a hockey adventure with
characters like
wild bill the goalie panda and wiley
riley smith
the golden knights have erased deficits
with drama and flair this past week but
every victory shouldn't be accompanied
by
a defibrillator it's been a suspenseful
stretch for vegas on saturday they
trailed one nothing with 90 seconds left
when
wild bill william carlson tied the game
they'd win in overtime
on monday vegas trailed 2-0 when two
goals by riley smith fired up the
comeback machine
again impressive and it's a bottom line
business for sure but
the path to victory shouldn't be such a
rocky road it didn't matter what you
know what the time of the
game was and what the score was this
team always just seemed to come back and
i think it's just kind of stuck with
this team as part of the culture i mean
if you look around the room we got
enough firepower and our d
we got one of the best decors in the
league that um
you know whatever the time of the game
is if we're down we're going to come
back and
you know the fact that we believe it
definitely helps a little bit too
i think that's contagious and uh it
starts with your leadership
but you know it's a nice feeling to have
as a coach
at the same time we've got to do a
better job of
not putting ourselves in the spot where
we have to
to come up with a huge third period in
order to win
even though no team in the league has
played more than four games the golden
knights are one of three to still be
undefeated
they just have a flair for being
dramatic christian